Hello everybody, my name is Marikplier, and welcome to Don't Take The Risk
Now I wanna warn you guys
This game is going to be very dark and very serious
It involves you getting a call from a wrong number
but the person on the other line is trying to find a suicide prevention hotline, so
this game covers very serious subject matters
and I want you guys to know that before going into it because
It, in all honesty, this game is probably not going to be what you would call "fun"
But it's going to be an experience and probably needs to be seen
The voice that came over was
Fun and charming / cool and alluring
Fun and charming?
Voice in game: H-hello?
Mark: Hello?
Voice in game: This is...this is the suicide hotline, yes?
Mark: Uh...no?
Oh boy, you have a limited amount of time to answer
Uh...no, unfortunately
Voice in game: No?
Mark: No
Voice in game: Oh
Mark: Ah
Voice in game: Oh, I see. Yes, this is clearly a sign that I should not have called
it-it was my mistake
I will hang up now
Mark: Waaiiit
Wait, hold on
Let's see
Ah
Uh, just kidding. Ah, that'd be the worse thing to say
You aren't going to hurt yourself, are you?
Voice in game: Why?
Mark: 'Cause I'm concerned?
Voice in game: It...it is not like you really know me on a personal level
Mark: Uh, a person on a suicide hotline wouldn't know you either
(Voice in game: There is...)
Voice in game: No one who cares about me
No one who loves me
I do not matter
Mark: Oh sheesh, that's not true
You do to me! I love you. That's not...that's not the right thing to say
Let's see
(sound of phone hanging up)
No, oh!
*sound of phone ringing*
Oh
*sound of phone ringing continues*
Automated voice: Please leave your message
*beep*
*text message sound*
Mark: Oh geez
Mark: You sure are persistent. You you. You
haha what a funny word
actually wait...lol is the correct term for that, isn't it?
but I'm not lolling on the floor
wait, that's not what it means, does it?
Huh
Let's see
It means "laugh out loud"
Right, okay well
I forgot if I was laughing out loud
I've been drinking so I can be forgiven
and taking pills
they're so stone cold
I rather have a warm slice of apple pie
There's an ice cream place with that name right?
Stone Cold Ice Cream?
Something doesn't sound right
Either way it sounds good, but I don't want something cold
I want to be warm
Let's see
Where are you?
In the middle of nowhere
Hey hey, you aren't trying to find out where I am, so you can send help, are you?
That would be smart
I'm trying to remember my address, but it's not coming to mind
12345 sounds good
2's my favorite number
Everyone knows 1's lonely
He should get together with...
What number do you think he should get together with?
Or maybe an alphabet would be better
A letter
like
a
a seems lonely
don't you think?
Let's see
city
What city are you in?
say
Are you okay?
*text message sound*
Sorry I blacked out for a moment there
What were you saying?
g
Oh wait, I can just scroll up
Too many texts
So much white
Should change my background before I die
What should be my last parting message
Why do you want to die?
Why not?
I'm tired of being alone
Waking up to no one
Talking to no one
Seeing no one
I guess I'm talking to you now
But you'll leave me
or die like everyone else I know
Never mind the nightmares
"Tomorrow, at dawn"
I don't know
"Tomorow, at dawn, i will go"
"Excuse me"
Can't think of English words
Translation
I hear goog translate is bad
Have you ever seen that one video?
They put words in a language and then another and another and another
Comes out garbled
Like telephone
Never played that game before, but I heard of it
Let me find you the video
Oh my God! It really goes there!
(Girl in video: So you know how)
Girl in video: If you put something into Google translate
Girl in video sings: Snow on the mountain tonight
Mark: I...I don't think I have time for this
I just picked that randomly
One of the first to show up
Just jump to the 49 second mark
The song doesn't start till then
Discrimination law might not be queen from the what I hear of election night
Hope nothing bad happens
I'm so out of the loop here
I have no idea what's going on
Just that everyone's mad
I'm not supposed to talk about politics am I?
It's taboo
Or make bad first impressions
Am I making a bad impression?
Oh whatever. I'm dying anyway
Let's see
I want to know about your city
What about it?
It's like any other city
Sort of?
Town might be more accurate
or not
Town have close-knit communities, right?
I've never felt close to anyone
I've grown close with the space around me
The leaves in autumn and the snows in winter
The melting heat in summer and the first shoots of spring
Don't know how to pronounce that
("Then we go")
"Bloom the beautifuls"
*sighs*
("Dandelions of gold")
"I'm sorry"
Not making sense
Let's see
What stores or restaurants are around you?
*text message sound*
I can't breathe
Help me
*text message sound*
Can you call the police?
Rage against the dying of the light
*text message sound*
*sound of phone ringing*
*sound of phone being answered*
*sound of person in game struggling to breathe*
*sound of phone ringing*
*sighs*
Like I said at the beginning of this
This game is not a "fun" game
This is about an experience that very few people go through, but people have to go through
I mean, even for the people that actually work the suicide hotline
this is the kind of things that they have to deal with, and be emotionally capable of handling
and it's a tough
it's a tough job
So, I'm going to
I'ma try the cool and alluring route
I'm not sure hot to go about this, but I don't know what the difference will be
(Voice in game: Hello?)
Mark: Hello?
Voice in game: This is...
This is the suicide hotline, yes?
Mark: Possibly
Uuuhhh
You have the wrong number
(Voice in game: Oh)
Voice in game: Oh I see
Yes, this is clearly a sign that I should not have called
It was my mistake
Mark: Not necessarily (Voice in game: I will hang up now)
Let's see
You're not going to hurt yourself are you?
Voice in game: Why?
It is not like you really know me on a personal level
Mark: Yeah, but I want to try
It seems like the difference between the voices is minimal
So...
Voice in game: There is no one who cares about me
No one who loves me
I do not matter
Mark: Let's see
Call that hotline. They care
(Voice in game: Okay)
Voice in game: "Goodbye"
*sound of phone hanging up*
Mark: Well shit
*sound of phone ringing*
Mark whispers: fuck
Automated voice: Please your message
Mark: I just don't want to have to listen to this again
(*sound of person in game in pain*)
All right
*sighs*
I'm gonna try this again
I just, I just, I stumbled over the right answers trying to
be quick about it
There are save options, so technically I could
do this quicker
So I'm, I'm just gonna go back to the first one and try to explore that to see if there's actually any fundamental differences, but
Voice in game: H-hello?
Mark: You do to me
Voice in game: Eh?
Mark: I love you
Voice in game: Do you really mean that miss?
Mark: Uuuhhh
Voice in game: You
love me?
Mark: I...I'm not one for lying
Voice in game: I...
want to see you
Mark: *inhales*
Mark: Man
*heavy exhale*
Voice in game: Please
Come see me Mademoiselle
Mark: That's quite a leap
Voice in game: My lovely mademoiselle
What is your name?
Mark: Oh man
Voice in game (sounding a little desperate): Who are you?
Tell me who you are
Mark: At least this gets him talking
I'm...
*chuckles*
"Mark"
*tries to hold in laughter*
Yep
Voice in game: What a beautiful sound
Mark: Glad you think so
Voice in game: Will you come see me?
Mark: Yeah, actually that's probably a good idea
Voice in game: I'll be waiting
Mark: Or maybe not a good idea
I have no idea
Voice in game: Oh
Let me give you the directions to my house
Uh, where are you coming from?
*sound of someone walking (up stairs?)*
Mark: Um
What, there was no option to alert the police or something?
*sound of someone knocking on a door*
*sound of door creaking open*
Voice in game: You
really came
Mark: Yes?
Question mark?
*whooshing sound*
Mark: He then moves to envelope you in his arms
Y-y-y-you hug him back?
*whooshing sound*
Voice in game: Come, come sit
Mark: Okay...
Voice in game: I can't believe you really exist
Mark: He leads you into the room by your hand. As you both settle on the edge of the bed, he doesn't release it
This is not
okay
Voice in game: You are so beautiful
Mark: Oh, this is 100% not okay
*heartbeat sounds*
Voice in game: Can I fetch you anything?
*heartbeat sounds in the background*
A bite to eat, a glass to drink?
Mark: What the fuck!
*heartbeat sounds in the background*
Voice in game: If you're cold, I can warm you up
Mark: Oh geez
*heartbeat sounds in the background*
*heartbeat sounds*
I don't want you to kill yourself
*heartbeat sounds in the background*
Voice in game: Darling, as long as you're with me, that thought will be the farthest thing from my mind
Very well
As you wish dearie
(Mark: Not so fast)
Voice in game (sounding aroused): There's so much I want to do with you
So much I want to know about you
Mark: What the fuck happened here?!
Voice in game (sounding sensual): I want to hear everything about you
Mark: Let's see
Can we do this when it's morning?
*Voice in game gasps*
Voice in game: You aren't
staying?
Mark (taken-aback): Noooo
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Voice in game: I do not want to be alone tonight
*heartbeat sound*
my love
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Mark: The fuck happened?
*heartbeat sound*
Mark: I'm not comfortable staying over...
Voice in game: We can go to a hotel
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Voice in game: if that's better
Mark: What the fuck?!
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Voice in game: Where do you want to stay?
I'll go wherever you want
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Mark: Uh
Mark: See you tomorrow
Voice in game: Please don't go
Mark: Oh
Aaahhh
*sound of door creaking shut*
*loud thud*
Mark: Oh boy
*sound of gun cocking
*sound of guy screaming*
*gunshot*
*music*
Mark: What kind of...?!?!
*music in the background*
*music*
Mark: What the fuck just happened?!
I have no idea
*exhales*
how to even talk about that
I just...I just don't understand
Voice in game: H-hello?
*exhales*
Voice in game: This is
Mark: Okay
Mark: Let's try this again I guess
Voice in game: This is the suic....
Mark: Let's try talking over the first...phone first
Voice in game: Calling or texting
Mark: Yeah...
Voice in game: I have the feeling you don't really want to see me
Mark: Ah...It's just that, you know, I get a, I get a call from a wrong number
I wanna make sure you're not gonna hurt yourself
but at the same time
that's pretty unsafe...
Voice in game: That's fine
I would not want to see me either
Mark: ooohh
Thank you for making me feel happy for a while
But I do not want to fake hope
*sound of phone hanging up*
Mark: God dammit
What the fuck
I mean
*soft music in the background*
I am
*sighs*
This is so bizarre
Like everything about this is so bizarre.
I don't even know how to describe what I'm seeing here
I don't even know how to deal with this
I mean, I know obviously it's a game and it's supposed to have like
a..a branching pathway to the endings but
I..I've gotten 1, 5, and 9
*unintelligible*
it's just so like
taking these down roads that's like skirting
danger for myself and then danger for this person
and it's just weird
like, how much do you help
like, how much do you put yourself in harm's way to help others
That's the most bizarre thing I've seen
Mark: I..I've never
Voice in game: H-hello?
Mark: had an experience like this. I've never put...I've never been put in these shoes
And I'll see you tomorrow?
Voice in game: Eh?
You...
*heartbeat sound*
Voice in game: I do not want to be alone tonight
*heartbeat sound in the background*
*heartbeat sound*
my love
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Mark: Let's see
*heartbeat sound*
Mark: Fine, just don't do anything weird to me
Voice in game: evil sounding laugh
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Voice in game: All right. Not for tonight then
*heartbeat sound*
Unless you want it
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Mark: You settle in bed. He curls his arms around your waist and holds you close
His chest is warm against your back
Voice in game: For the first time in a long while
I'm looking forward to tomorrow
I want to spend the whole day with you
I want to make beautiful memories with ma belle
Lights that will sparkle when times grow cold and dark
Light me up, ma chérie
I love you
Mon amour
Oh mon trésor (Translation: My treasure)
You hair is as smooth as silk
Your smile shines brighter than every star in the galaxy
You are the living incarnation of the phrase, "looks that can kill"
Not even the most skilled author could put my feelings for you into words
I could go on and on, but
your divinity leaves me speechless
Every word I say is merely a grain of sand in a desert of love
I want you to remember something, darling
No matter what you say
No matter what you do
I will still love you
Forever
and always
Oh
Mon trésor (Translation: My treasure)
Your hair is as smooth as...
Mark (grossed out): Ok, all right, ok, all right, ok, all right, ok
Oooooooh..I've never felt so creeped out in my liiiiiiiiiffffeeee
Oh geez
He didn't kill himself
But it was built on a lie, so you can't say that was good, and
my God
The situation I get myself into
that was nooooooooot
okaaaaay
Call the suicide hotline
Voice in game: The reason you said you loved me
the reason you're acting like you care
You want me to call the hotline
to pawn me off to someone else
Mark: No
Mark whispers: I just don't want you to kill yourself
I don't know how to help you. They can
Voice in game: Fine.
Voice in game: I will
Then, I would like my privacy
Mark: No
I don't trust you
Voice in game: You would be right not to trust me
*heartbeat sound*
Voice in game: You don't know what kind of man I am
*heartbeat sound in the background*
*heartbeat sound*
Or just how hungry I am
*heartbeat sound in the background*
*heartbeat sound*
I want to eat you up mademoiselle
*heartbeat sound in the background*
*heartbeat sound*
Mark: You don't scare me
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Voice in game: Mmm but I should
*heartbeat sound*
Mark: He presses his mouth against yours
T-tongue....(sassily) no
*slap noise*
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Voice in game: Evil laugh
*heartbeat sound*
Voice in game: You really aren't scared of me, are you?
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Mark: Oh geez
Voice in game: Then, do you want to play, love?
*heartbeat sound in the background*
*heartbeat noise*
Mark: Let's see
Mark: You threw your full....shove him down
*loud noise*
Voice in game: Ngh
Voice in game: *evil laugh*
You win
Now what
kitten?
*heartbeat sound*
Mark: Let's see
Mark: I'm watching over you until you come to your senses
Voice in game: All night?
*heartbeat sound in the background*
*heartbeat sound*
Voice in game: Mm...not a bad way to spend an evening
*heartbeat sound in the background*
But
There is something I don't understand
*heartbeat sound in the background*
Why do you care?
Mark: Oh geez
Because life is precious
Voice in game: Precious
huh?
If I had your love
Ah, but I shouldn't dream too far now
I'll turn in for the night then
Better be careful you don't nod off
Not that I would complain.
Just...don't hold me responsible for what I do
to you or me.
*evil chuckle*
Oh, mon trésor. (Translation: Oh, my treasure)
Your hair is as smooth as silk.
Your smile shines brighter than every star in the galaxy
You are the living in...
Mark: I'm
I have no idea what to say about this.
This is such a bizarre experience!
I-it's just so weird
'Cause it's like, i-it really is that
I-it lives up to its name! It's like don't take this risk.
It's...i-it's so weird.
Y-you hold yourself accountable for his death, if you
If you don't go over to his place and talk to him
and yet going over to his place, you don't know where he's at in his mind
And he could be dangerous!
It is a stranger!
What line do you cross to help a stranger?
What line do you, like, cross to...uh...save yourself?
Like I
That is so weird!
I didn't get all the endings. I need to find if there is like uh
I-I need to look up a walkthrough and see if there is actually like
a good ending out of this
So I'll be right back
There's ending number one which was the first one we got
"Stay with me forever" which we got
"Keep your eye on me"
"Manslaughter"?
Oh geez
You rammed his...Oh no.
Oh, if I rammed his head against the wall, it would have killed him?
"Shot him in the head"
"Bleeding out"
*mumbling* calling the police
Geez
"Risky love"
"Unknown"
That's so weird!
So there are only nine endings and then
Some extra things that you can do that's...
Apparently there're only nine endings
and none of them end well
In the traditional sense except for
watching over him
That's so bizarre!
I don't even know how to talk about that!
I-I don't even know what to say about this!
Because this is obviously not a typical scenario
in a suicide hotline. This isn't anywhere near the norm
This is obviously a story and the character portrayed here
isn't
the normal person calling into the suicide hotline.
I wanna say that, obviously.
This is a horrrrrrrifiying story.
Where no good option seems to be coming out of this other than putting yourself at risk
and like, determining what line
do you-do you cross to try to save someone
in this situation?
But in reality,
and I wanna make a very distinct difference between this game and reality
Suicide is something that affects everybody's lives
Whether it's you directly, or someone you know
We all have been touched by it in one way or another
and it's such a serious subject and I
always wanna make sure that it's given the gravity
that it is due
And I also wanna say
uh, we are doing today, the day that this video is released
A-a charity livestream for the crisis text line
And if you are watching this in the future you may still be able to catch it
fo-'cause it's a twelve hour livestream
We're gonna be going all day
and hopefully provide a day full of fun
and laughter
and joy
that can kinda juxtapose the-the harrowing feeling of this game here
And also bring light to a lot of people's lives
and give them an opportunity to reach out and get help
if they need it. Because that's what the crisis text line does
I-I-If it- even if it's not suicide itself
Even if you're in any sort of other crisis, you can reach out
to the number
and get someone who is ready and willing to help you
and listen
seriously listen
And that is sometimes so key
in times like this
So, I-I just obviously want to make the distinction that this is a game
And this is reality
And in reality, we need to be there to help people
And we need be there
And we need to be there for each other *Mark looks at camera*
Because it...I know for a fact in this community, there are thousands of people who are struggling
with depression and suicidal thoughts every day
And I want you to know
that life is worth living. Even if those words seem empty to you
it is
And there are people that care, even if it seems like you're in the darkest,
most isolated of places
We really do care, and we really wanna be there for you
And there are so many resources that are there to help
So anyway, I'll leave it at that
Today we are going to be livestreaming
You can probably catch the recording if you get to this video late
But just...thank you everybody so much for watching
Check the description for information. I'll try to put a link to the livestream and any other resources I can
So thank you again
And as always
I will see you
in the next video
Buh-bye!